loin des outrances il ya quelque chose
qui n'a pas l'air si outrancier que ça
d'ailleurs c'est la chose la plus soft
que j'ai entendu et c'est pour cette
raison que c'est sur cela que je vais
m'attacher lacombe c'est sur le mode de
dictature dire que la france est une
dictature même sanitaires et quelque
chose d'obscène d'abord parce que les
gens qui prenons ce genre de phrases
n'ont jamais mis les pieds en
afghanistan en corée du nord ou en chine
et que là ils verraient véritablement
qu'une dictature c'est quelqu'un qui
lorsqu'il déborde un peu se fait tout
simplement tuer ou rentrer chez lui voit
sa famille massacrée si on pouvait déjà
retiré ce mot du vocable des
manifestants ça serait pas mal l'étoile
jaune c'est tellement affligeant qu'il
faut vraiment comprendre qu'on est en
france il y a qu'en france qu'on peut
goodwin is est à ce point là un débat je
peux vous dire que j'ai été j'aime pas
ce genre de comparaison c'est toujours
facile intellectuellement j'étais à
beyrouth cet été je peux vous dire qu'il
rêverait d'un débat sur le code vide il
rêverait d'un débat sur le personnel
soignant ils n'ont plus d'essence plus
d'eau électricité et les banques les
brancards les ambulances sera placé dans
la rue par des brancards et s'ils
voulaient quand on revient en france on
s'aperçoit malgré tout que ces débats
gnui disait sont quand même des débats
d'enfant gâté maintenir cette
proposition de retirer le mot dictature
qui semble excessif à yann moix et a
beaucoup et à moi autant dire alors ben
moi je suis pas d'accord parce que je
pense qu'on est dans une dictature
sanitaires à partir et vous savez
pourquoi vous avez le droit de dire que
dans dictature parce que vous êtes dans
une démocratie mais échoue
alors merci je pense qu'on est dans une
dictature sanitaires tout simplement
parce qu'à partir du moment où on ne
peut plus se déplacer comme on veut moi
qui viens de la bretagne il a fallu que
je fasse donc se passe sanitaires pour
pouvoir venir sinon je n'avais pas le
droit de prendre le train donc à partir
du moment où on porte atteinte à mes
libertés j'estime que je suis dans une
dictature et vous êtes en danger de mort
madame non mais pas du tout
selon bernard yade a évoqué c'est pas sa
dictature soyons sérieux alors tu as le
droit de le penser et de le dire mais
c'est pas ça c'est bon
droit de le consommer
et de le dire et de penser parce que
vous n'êtes pas dans une dictature mais
ça me paraît incroyable qu'on ne puisse
pas en france actuellement est d'être
dans l'opposition
de faire une opposition chercher une
démocratie non mais vous êtes dans
l'opposition parce que c'est vous en
avez fait un objet politique quel est le
rapport entre les gilet jaune au
démarrage sur les ronds-points qui
manifestaient légitimement le pouvoir
d'achat et les maires
je suis athée sur celles définies juste
un point est ce que vous pensez aux 300
soignants qui sont partis dans les
dom-tom eux pour aller soigner nos
compatriotes est-ce que c'est plus dur
pour war room à l'orangé le régime in us
walter si je
n'entends démocratrie nous répondait à
sa ensuite ce monsieur parle de répondre
ja on va dire 50% de la crise sanitaire
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui est dû
au fait qu'ils queue leu leu
l'hôpital a été mal géré et on a
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron et monsieur
olivier vers ans qui continue à fermer
des lits mais comment va-t-on la
continuer à fermer d'élise bien sûr que
sévère raclée de la parole et des
représentants de la dictature n'en
donnait elle demande à
bruno bonnet représentant officiel de la
dictature stop on peut pas vous les
verrez ce des minutes la parole circule
on a effectivement eu pendant une
trentaine d'années des fermetures de
lits et probablement une gestion de
l'hôpital qui était difficile donc allez
pas mettre ça sur les quatre dernières
années
comme hier la corrida fait qui a eu des
lits supplémentaires qui ont été mis non
urgent d'étendre des irp et rennes c'est
une montée arrivant de 3,4 milliards
d'euros ou l'hôpital arrêter de dire
c'est l'antenne nation le droit de venir
à point parce que parce que c'est bien
de dire on a le droit de le dire ne pas
dire d'être d'avoir une opinion de saxe
est où ça s'est super bien et on a des
lois salle il ya un truc qui s'appelle
la loi moi je roule à 30 km heure
maintenant dans paris oui j'aurais bien
envie de rouler à 50 eh bien vous si oui
le trader avait un passionné ça
s'appelle la loi et
lycées votre choix mais vous arrêtez de
faire croire que c'est au nom de la
liberté qu'on va faire ce qu'on veut
parce que moi au nom de la liberté